moi j'habite à lviv et williams et aux
jeunes par ce repos mais j'aime venir
une fois par semaine à faire là quoi
tiennent et paix arrive deux ans ils
rentrent sont déçus bien de femmes
savaient combien de femmes sur la ils
sont tous bons imaginons qu'ils partent
qu'ils vont voir le propriétaire qui a
the rule d'avoir beaucoup de 2 des
transiliens ses étudiants mais il reste
sous là et puis rien il ment bon on va
avoir une journée au super et là dans
quelques mois
c'est eux qui ont la piscine tout mais
c'est ça c'est ça le le brûlage ses
soeurs c'est ce dont on a peur mais
c'est ça qui va lever 6 à macha allah
faut voter parti québécois parce que
c'est le seul parti qui décide de passer
la nouvelle fois sans merci